[Musique]
non emmanuel macron candidate est en
train de s'excuser de tout ce qui est
manuel macron président n'a pas fait
enfin on a on voit bien le président de
la république aujourd'hui c'est
au pied du pont de bezons sur le lieu
même de la répression du 17 octobre 1961
une minute de silence
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république française assisté à cet
hommage en 60 ans les mots sont justes
c'est inexcusable et cela doit être
ouvert comme une sorte de finalement de
livres qui appartient maintenant au
passé sur lequel nous sommes capables de
faire la lumière dizaines de morts de ce
jour là pour vous ne sont pas forcément
inexcusable comme des prisonniers glisy
mais tout autant que les vingt-deux
policiers morts dans des attentats fln
cette même année qui ont été en partie à
l'origine de cette sanglante répression
je pense qu'il faut aller encore
reconnaître la responsabilité de l'état
français et avoir une journée de
commémoration c'est le sens de la
composition de loi présenté par le maire
socialiste au sénat le problème de du
bilan macron c'est que c'est un bilan
désastreux pour l'économie et il faut
maintenant que les français aient
conscience qu'il faut le mettre hors
d'état de nuire car il a fait beaucoup
de dégâts sur notre pays je suis révolté
vous dénoncez la kabbale d omar sy la
cavale d'un homme a en tout cas on voit
bien que c'était une opération qui a été
menée pour
essayé de m'abattre d'ailleurs
malheureusement ça a fonctionné du point
de vue politique la victoire est
possible
ne croyez pas que je le dise seulement
parce que
vous confidence de nicolas hulot jadot
c'est le pire c'est ce qu'il m'avait dit
oui parce qu'il trouvait que c'était lui
qui dès le début l'avait attaqué sans
relâche et avec une mauvaise foi souvent
considérables il a continué bon ça lui a
permis peut-être de prendre une forme de
leadership cinq ans de macron plus c'est
le statu quo donc c'est le chaos
écologique social démocratique que
zemmour j'ai eu le petit collabos de
salon qui ont pour un grand résistant
même pas en rêve
à droite comme on voudrait nous le faire
croire parce qu'on essaie de les bourrer
le crâne avec des idées de racisme de
haine des musulmans et d'absurde égoïsme
social eric zemmour je n'étais pas une
importance personnel c'est un des
visages que ce qui est malheureusement
longue tradition notre pays l'extrême
droite française
henneuse antisémites ne l'oublierons
jamais même quand la presse par daby
plus acceptable extrêmement une
française est par essence antisémite il
faut qu'ils se retrouvent il faut que
celui qui sera le mieux placé en février
prochain se prennent le pas sur l'autre
et que celui qui est le moins placé cède
élus les appels à voter pour celui qui
sera en tête flexion du pré dont la
république au suffrage universel c'est
la volonté pour le général de gaulle que
le président se tiennent un certain
niveau et qu'il embrasse qu'il embrasse
le sort de la france c'est pas rien vous
comprenez moi je ne refuse de descendre
de ce niveau là est ce que cette
attitude elle commence par un petit peu
vous agacer
au nom du tout au rien de maga fia que
les journalistes qui me posent des
questions embêtante qui m'agace quand je
dis marine le pen ne gagnera jamais je
dis ce que tout le monde sait on le sait
depuis son débat de 2017 à la télévision
on le sait depuis les élections
régionales vous l'avez entendu les mots
sont durs elle est mauvaise les français
ont compris qu'elle ne gagnera le
sondage dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
mais qu'est-ce que vous révéler sa vraie
dit non moi je vais rentrer dans votre
jeu après deux jours passés dans l' iss
il est l'heure de redescendre pour le
réalisateur clint shipping co et
l'actrice yun lee ap racing il était
arrivé le 5 octobre dernier sourire aux
lèvres avec une mission inédite tourner
un long métrage dans l'espace